live from financial peace Plaza
it's the Dave Ramsey show in the lobby
of financial peace Plaza Chad and Ashley
are with us what's up guys what's that
Dave welcome welcome where you guys live
Amarillo Texas hey what brings you to
Nashville Tennessee we're here to do our
debt-free screen that's a bit of a trek
yes sir yeah you really can't get from
Amarillo to Nashville can you
well not quickly we gotta go to Denver
first yeah you gotta go to LA in back
yeah yeah oh my gosh well welcome it's
good to have you I assume you're here to
do a debt-free screen yes I love it how
much debt have you paid off we paid off
142,000 goodness gracious yes sir how
long did that take you twenty nine
months that's Rowdy making what kind of
money during this time we started off at
seventy three thousand and last year we
were around ninety excellent a hundred
and forty two thousand dollars what do
you buy well we bought everything cars
and student loans and everything car
payments we sold two cars I'm right
whenever we started your program what
kind of cars did you sell him for how
much we sold
she had a brand-new Mustang g/t no we
underlined oh it was so pretty and we
had a GMC Acadia oh man you guys have
you got good cars
oh they were expendable we're Chauncey
yeah that's really you so was $60,000
were the cars yes right now my gosh
that's incredible out of the 142 what
was the rest of it um we had twenty
thousand dollars in student loans um ten
thousand and medical bills and the rest
was credit cards see you guys were just
like normal
absolutely I mean you got stuck you're
not that young so you got started early
being dumb yeah wait wait wait
today's her birthday by the way I was I
had to do that I'm sorry I heard the
rumor I said yeah you're not that old
how old are you
I'm only eight she just turned 29 looks
like a year is funny how that works look
at you robbing the cradle yeah hello
that's fun
I married an older woman too by about
four months it's a good idea I get to
make fun of her four months a year yeah
oh my goodness that's great so very cool
what got you started on this 29 months
ago well I was Drive
a truck at the time just being ordinary
and I heard your show on the radio and I
thought yes ordinary sucks I want to go
do something and so I went home and I
told her about it and at the time we
weren't getting along very good at all
oh I didn't think there was a chance she
would listen to me and she did and there
was there was some silent protest uh-huh
so because you didn't believe did you
he'd hurt schemes of scams before not
necessarily schemes and scams but I mean
I didn't really trust much that he said
so why would I let him tell me what to
do with my money I got you know okay
when we did we were the total opposite
of what you said everything was separate
and we didn't communicate about a thing
so what was a lot of that about the
money stress a lot of it was yeah
so his getting rid of the dad helped all
of that oh you saved our marriage
totally one percent we were we wouldn't
be here right now if it wasn't for you
well I'm honored I didn't do it you did
it I just showed you how yeah but I'm
proud of you I'm really proud of you
that's cool you're way too cute a couple
to be separated I know right that's it
and the humility to it's a strong suit
very cool well you're making really good
money you don't have a payment in the
world and you've been married what six
years now six years I was guessing was a
pretty good guess it wasn't in three
years of that or two and a half years of
that you've been fighting this debt
monster together yes there and so when
you started out when you very first
started once you got past the silent
treatment and you started actually
believing it was going to happen
actually what was the toughest thing
about those first few months was it
selling those cars it was like being
newlyweds all over again we had to
figure out how to be married cuz we
hadn't done it before
Wow and those those first few months
years that we were together we weren't
really a married couple more like
roommates
yeah um and so when when he brought that
into our marriage and he stepped into
the role of a spiritual leader um I had
to I had to listen and I had to learn
how to be a submissive proverbs 31 wife
which is something I still work on um
but it settled us into our roles in our
marriage and
we had to figure it out it was like
meeting two totally new people yeah you
guys got you guys got a complete work
over didn't you oh this is pretty
amazing
yes so um that's an interesting thing
because I take it you said rolls and he
stepped into that did you have a
spiritual experience during this time -
are you were already in church I grew up
in church I wasn't doing my job as a man
though I was I was not a good husband I
wasn't a leader I didn't know what it
was like to lead and my leader you don't
mean boss right our audience to hear
bossing her around was that because I
got a feeling she don't do boss she
doesn't do boss
yeah no it's not servant leadership that
you talked about it I studied you I'm
teaching about that a lot and it really
spoke to me okay and that was that's
what won her over in the end was putting
her first and serving her and she felt
loved yes absolutely
is that right I heard up at work no no
definitely um loved and and worthy
mm-hmm and appreciated and when you when
your yoke equally the burden becomes
much lighter yeah it sure does
sure does so how hard was it sell the
cars oh it was hard it was hurt mostly
just because we're so upside down we
couldn't find anybody to biom want you
what you emotionally let go him you
couldn't get rid of stupid that nobody
wanted him so we ended up rolling a lot
of it into the car that we we spent a
long time paying that off for her so
okay so what are you driving now I am
driving a no7 Corolla cool and she's
still driving the car we sold the other
two for an O for expedition okay not bad
not bad that's doable I like it
I'm attached now because it's it's nice
it's got the heated seats and everything
but it's old enough that when I back
into something he has no idea like it
doesn't even matter unless you really
got a rapport you yeah it's usually
inanimate objects like dumpsters and
trees
it's all enough it's like oh we don't
even need to let him look at it don't
worry about the tree he's pay no
attention to the tree the leaning tree
in the yard that's all alaria so what do
you tell people that the secret is to
paying off a hundred and forty two
thousand dollars in 29 months I tell
them it's diligence and communication
that diligence that you've talked about
over and over excellence over time and
taking it one day at a time and just
doing your best that day and talking to
your wife I married up you know this is
the secret to my success right here so
amen um it's easy for me but free other
guys out there I don't know what you are
going to do Zig Ziglar is a buddy of my
before he passed away he told me he said
Dave I don't respect a man they can't
marry up and I deeply respect you so
it's a good thing that's a good thing
guys well you guys are absolutely
incredible congratulations very very
proud of you I mean you really had a
total life make oh yes and and the Money
Makeover just part of it hey before we
leave because you get your so you know
the ability to put a turn of phrase on
things so well talk to that couple
actually talk to that lady who's scared
and she's you three years ago and
somehow tell her that it can really
happen if she makes the decision to work
together or their spouse it's listening
to that voice that you try to ignore um
for such a long time I I would hear
people in church and friends that we had
and they're like me and God talks to me
all the time like me God doesn't ever
talk to me it turns out he has been I
just I wasn't listening mm-hmm um and
usually the thing that you're fighting
um the hardest and not wanting to do it
all is exactly where you're supposed to
be and once I let go of that and once I
let go of the restrictions I put on
myself and what I thought I was supposed
to be as a woman and as a wife and all
these roles I was supposed to maintain
once I let that go and just decided to
let God direct my
life mm-hmm this is what happened hmm um
and just try it three years ago I mean
we didn't have anything better to do I
mean nothing else was working so why not
it was either try this or kill him yeah
exactly
still here oh yeah just just do it why
not
if it doesn't work I'll Baker go home if
it doesn't work you can always go back
to doing it the way you were exactly
like it good word you guys are
incredible all right counted down 142
thousand dollars at 29 months paid off
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one they are absolutely awesome